>>Marisa: We are very excited today to welcome
Christy Turlington here. We're gonna get to
see a little bit of the new film that's debuting
this spring as well as get some questions
time for Christy. And I have a little, a little
bio here that's been prepared for her so I'll
just go ahead and read that.
With more than 25 years at the forefront of
the fashion industry, having graced every
magazine from the cover of Vogue to Time,
Christy Turlington has established a diverse
career as a model, writer, entrepreneur, spokesperson,
advocate, and now a film maker. Philanthropy
and service has been a long part of Christy's
personal and professional mission to make
a lasting impact on the world.
In 2005 she began working with the international
humanitarian organization CARE and has since
become their advocate for maternal health.
She has also been an ambassador for RED since
their launch in 2006. Her work on behalf of
CARE and RED inspired her to pursue a master's
in public health at Columbia University Mailman's
School where she's currently enrolled.
In 2008, Christy began work on a documentary
film profiling the status of maternal health
worldwide. In her gripping directorial debut
Christy shares the following, the powerful
stories of an at risk pregnant woman in four
different parts of the world including a remote
Maasai tribe in Tanzania, a slum in Bangladesh,
a post abortion care ward in Guatemala, and
a prenatal clinic in the United States. "No
Woman, No Cry" made its world premier at the
2010 Tribeca Film Festival in New York City
with U.S. television broadcasts premiering
on May 7, 2011 on the new Oprah Winfrey Network.
Concurrent with the debut of her documentary,
Christy launched Every Mother Counts an advocacy
and mobilization campaign to increase educational
support for maternal and child health.
Today Christy joins us to talk about her documentary.
I wanna welcome Christy to tell us a little
bit about the film to start.
[applause]
>>Christy Turlington: Thank you Marissa.
I'm thrilled to be here today to share this
film it's really been a labor of love and
a very passionate issue for me for the last
three years, but actually for the last seven
and a half years because you'll see at the
beginning of the film that it's an incredibly
personal story as well. This is just the first
part of it, it's just through Tanzania, but
I do encourage you to see the film when it
comes out on the 7th of May and I hope you
enjoy it. I look forward to talking afterwards.
Thank you.
>>Marisa: It's beautifully told. So I guess
I'd like to understand a little bit about
how did you decide to make the movie?
>>Christy Turlington: Well I had that experience
at the beginning with Grace and I learned
about the statistics, the global statistics
around maternal mortality, but it was really
actually a couple years later, when I was
pregnant with my second child, that I started
to do a little bit of traveling with the humanitarian
aid organization, CARE.
And one of the first places we visited was
to El Salvador which is where my mom is from
and I think I was about six and half, seven
months pregnant. We visited a small community
in a rural area where it was a water project
and because they were providing some water
and some access to water for women who mostly
do the water collection, they were using this
opportunity to also educate, give some prenatal
and postnatal care to some women in the area.
And a lot of the women were in the same state
of their pregnancies as I was or had just
had babies and I think that was the moment
where I sort of thought, "Oh if I lived here
and I had had my complication, I would be
dead." No doubt about it. There was no running
water, there was no electricity, there were
no paved roads, I hadn't seen an ambulance
or a hospital facility for miles getting out
to that area. And that's when I had the moment
of like this is something that I think I can
contribute to.
And then about a year later I traveled again
to Peru or to Peru to an indigenous population
in the highlands. And I saw a success story
also with CARE in a partnership between CARE,
Columbia University, and the local government
where they were able to reduce maternal deaths
in half in less than five years. And I think
seeing how they were able to do that and how
low cost so many of the solutions were, that's
what sort of floored me and I thought, "This
is doable. These are hundreds of thousands
of lives, but 90 percent of them are preventable.
Why aren't we doing a better job? What can
be done?"
And I'm not a filmmaker by training, but my
husband's a filmmaker and a lot of our friends
are filmmakers and I thought, "This is a story
that needs, these are stories that need to
be told," and so I set out to make a movie
and to pull any resource that I had together
to be able to make this to connect people
like yourselves to the issue.
>>Marisa: And how did you find the women and
how did you choose the locations? I'm guessing
that probably out of the four that are in
the movie, but there probably were many more
that you interacted with over that time.
>>Christy Turlington: There were. There are
countless women's stories we've collected.
Well I wanted to show that it was a global
tragedy. So it was very important to me that
we look at obviously where the highest burdens
are which is in sub-Saharan Africa and I chose
Tanzania for a few reasons: one, in that there's
political will there. The President of Tanzania
has been very vocal and he's taken a real
leadership role with regards to MDG 4 & 5
which are around infant mortality and maternal
mortality. And so that is a big thing I wanted
to find countries that were sort of primed
for success. It's also one of the first countries
I traveled to in Africa 21 years ago and so
I have friends there, I feel comfortable there
and familiar there. So we chose it for that
reason and then we picked Northern Tanzania
where the roads are better thinking that if
we got to see that referral process from clinic
to hospital that we could do it often times
if we needed to.
But as you could see with Janet, even though
she didn't live so, so far away, I mean it's
still miles away from a road and miles away
from the hospital that she had to go to.
In Guatemala, we ended up -- through Planned
Parenthood, we found an obstetrician who was
just so remarkable that we actually picked
the country because of her. I wanted to look
at a country that had a high indigenous population
because those women that are the most disenfranchised
in a society. And so we picked it because
it was surrounded by very, very conservative
countries and yet it was this little country
where it had this one woman, she's like the
sole Planned Parenthood provider in that country,
and she was also eight months pregnant herself.
So she was just incredible.
We picked Bangladesh. It's where the second
highest burden is after Sub-Saharan Africa
which is in Southeast Asia. There are a lot
of incredible things happening in Bangladesh.
It's a small country and they have sort of
family planning somewhat under control. A
lot of women have controlled the amount of
children that they have. However, they don't
have their babies in facilities. And I think
90 percent of them choose to have a child
at home -- which is fine if you have a clean
home and you have access to water and health
care workers, but they often do it totally
by themselves. So we wanted to examine what
were the cultural barriers and some of the
social norms that were preventing them from
seeking care if it was in fact offered.
And then the last being the U.S. I just thought
it was so important -- I live in the U.S.
I had my children in the U.S. I think it's
important because the audiences that I geared
this film for live here that we bring it close
to home. And, of course, as we were making
the movie we were going through this huge
process in the States about health care reform
and still are, so it seemed really important
to tie that piece into it and to weave it
through.
And for all of the countries that I've shown
this film in, they're all the most shocked
actually about the U.S. In the UK, they just
couldn't believe that so many women are not
provided for particularly as pregnant people.
>>Marisa: I think one of the interesting scenes
in there and I imagine it happened several
times over making the movie was when they
asked you for help. And I wondered if you
had sort of guidance in terms of how did you
handle that, when did you intervene, when
did you not intervene. I think it must have
been really, you would definitely wanna help
but at sometimes then you're also changing
the story that you're observing and --
>>Christy Turlington: Exactly.
>>female #1: it's a difficult balance.
>>Christy Turlington: It was a difficult balance.
I mean we went in thinking we are gonna be
around some scenarios which will be, they'll
be precarious and they'll be dangerous and
we will help people get to the care that they
need, but we did really wanna understand what
would happen if we weren't here. And so while
we were dealing with it, I mean we were also
filming several stories at the same time so
at the same time as Janet Lightness had come
in, the 16 year old at the end, and we were
filming her story very carefully too. So it
was really hard to kind of know what was gonna
happen to anyone and they both ended up having
to go-go to get care at the hospital.
But it was very challenging to know like what's
the moment. So we had some of our crew which
was quite small starting to work on providing
transportation, going to go negotiate with
the driver down the road to make sure that
we could get transportation for her even if
we didn't go with her and we ended up just
deciding, "You know what we're just gonna
go with her. We're just gonna see what happens."
And thank goodness we were because obviously
everyday there's not a van full of Mazungu
as we're called [laughs] around to help.
>>Marisa: And this is your first turn as a
filmmaker. So what were some of the biggest
surprises and challenges?
>>Christy Turlington: It was such an extraordinary
experience and my producer is a friend, a
friend who's a mom in my neighborhood in New
York and she's been a part of a lot of productions
for documentaries and she pulled together
a team for me that were incredible, so I was
really learning all the time. But we were
a team of women and we worked with a local
producer in each of the countries so that
we would have somebody to speak the local
dialect and also they were filmmakers in their
own right so we tried to provide some work
opportunity as well for filmmakers in each
of the countries.
But I just love, I love to travel and I love
to be a part of really embedded into a part
of the world that we are and in all of my
travels through my career and just aside of
my career, I haven't really been able to sort
of indulge that part of like really being
for two weeks at a time with a community of
people and being let into their lives in some
of the most intimate moments that women will
ever have.
So the fact that women allowed us in at that
time and again we would introduce ourselves,
explain what we were trying to do, always
get permission, and treat women with dignity
and respect at all times. But women started
to seek us out. It was some, I mean Janet
was one of those people I think she just saw
this is an opportunity, "I think these people
can help me." So she kind of as much as we
found her, she also sought us out and that
happened in each of the countries in some
way.
>>Marisa: And do you think that you'll do
more film making in the future? Are there
other films that you'd like to make?
>>Christy Turlington: I think I will actually.
I hadn't set out to -- this story really,
this issue really inspired me. But in editing
the film, there were countless stories I mean
we could have told so many stories because
you know maternal mortality is I think the
red flag to a very large maternal health issue
which really boils down to equity. And so
numerous times, it was really like this could
be a movie about religion and reproductive
health, this could be a movie about just rights
and the lack of knowledge of human rights.
There were so many different pieces to it
and so there are so many stories still to
be told and I think I will go and do them.
I just have to see this one through and I'm
committed at least through 2015 [laughs] with
my advocacy strategy so.
>>Marisa: So tell us a little bit about the
advocacy strategy. What do you expect to come
out of this? What would you like to see happen?
How can all of us help support the cause?
>>Christy Turlington: Well I, as I was editing
the movie also I mean you create like a social
issue documentary to try to create real change
and I think the film is an amazing opportunity
to be able to show stories about women in
their own language and their own voices like
what-what their lives are like. However, at
the end of a movie that moves you and hopefully
inspires you in some way, you do wanna know,
"What can I do."
So "Every Mother Counts" is a way to create
some actionable opportunities for people to
be able to engage on a number of different
levels. I mean there are policy pieces of
this that are clearly important because policy
in the U.S. reflects the policy [chuckles]
around the world particularly with reproductive
rights and contraception and family planning
and those types of things.
But also, you know, just ways to feel like
you've contributed in a meaningful way. And
I feel that this is an issue that really touches
everybody: men, women, families. Because we've
all come into the world through this process.
It's truly a universal issue. If we haven't
had children ourselves, our partners, our
friends, our sisters, our friends have gone
through this process and I think we all know
somebody who had some slight complication,
some fearful moment in their pregnancy that
I think we can identify with women like the
ones that are presented in the film and like
the "what if", "what if I'd been there or
there?" The randomness of it all.
So I feel that it's something that each of
us can do something. Each of us had our own
set of resources that we can think of a way
to do something but sharing the stories, inviting
people to see the film, to know about the
issue. Our website -- everymothercounts.org
-- is set up to learn more and go to the next
level. We've created some education modules
that are free and downloadable from our site
and we're trying to have our site be a way,
a resource really to lead you to the things,
the innovations that are in this area. I mean
there's some amazing high tech, low tech solutions
to this issue, and trying to invite and identify
the ones that we think are the most exciting
and the most useful right now.
But we would love [chuckles] any ideas you
have. I think you all in your specific area
of expertise and interests would have so much
to contribute that I have no knowledge or
skills [laughs]. So I would love, I would
love help and partnership in any way.
>>Marisa: So changing gears from the film
a little bit, I think that all of us are very
interested 'cause you've had one of the most
multifaceted careers of anyone certainly I've
ever met, and I wanted to explore a little
bit about each of those and so I thought maybe
we could start with your modeling days. A
little bit about what they were like, how
you got into the business in the first place.
I think it's interesting for people to hear
about all the different career shifts and
experiences you've had.
>>Christy Turlington: Sure. Well I grew up
in the East Bay actually. I was born in Walnut
Creek and I grew up in Danville and I grew
up riding horses. My sisters and I we all
rode and competed in horseback riding. And
my parents worked for Pan Am and they were
big travelers and so we grew up sort of traveling
a lot around the world.
But we lived in Florida for a brief time because
Pan Am was based there and my dad was a training
captain. And at that time is when I got sort
of discovered and it was through my horseback
riding. Actually a photographer saw my sister
and I riding horses and asked our mom if he
could take our picture and I was like 14 with
braces and everything and my sister was like,
"That would be cool." So we did it and I became
the tall one and she didn't grow very tall
and so I had [chuckles] a career [laughs].
But yeah I so I started working when I moved
back here as a teenager in high school I started
-- I would take the bus, the BART bus, and
take BART into the city and I would work for
the department stores and that kind of thing.
And then I went to New York and sort of stayed
there from there and I didn't wanna come back
after experience a little bit of independence
and and the travel I was really hard to go
back to the suburbs [laughs] to high school.
But my mom pushed me to finish my high school
degree which was smart because then I went
back to school, to NYU, at 25 when I was kind
of burnt out with my career. And I got a degree
in comparative religion and Eastern philosophy.
And I started practicing Yoga as a teenager
but I started to really practice very regularly
at that time.
And then started a couple of businesses after
that. I started a skin care business that
was based on the principles of Ayurveda, a
sister philosophy to Yoga and also an apparel
line in partnership with Puma which was also
around Yoga and lifestyle of Yoga. And so
I did that for a while and I wrote a book
about Yoga called "Living Yoga: Creating a
Life Practice". And what else did I do [laughs]
--
>>Marisa: And tell us a little bit about Yoga.
So how often do you practice it, for what
duration? Do you like to do it in a group,
do you do it at home? Tell us a little bit
about your Yoga practice.
>>Christy Turlington: My Yoga practice these
days is really my advocacy. I, seva is a big
part of, it's one of the principles of Yoga
and honestly I mean I wish I could practice
more of the physical aspect of it, but I just
don't have enough time in the day these days.
[laughs] I really view my service and the
work that I do in this area as my Yoga, and
also the way that I mother my children is
really my Yoga. I mean to me it's really the
way that I view the world and my perspective
of the world and I do consider it a life practice
so while I don't get to do as much physical
Yoga at the moment, I do whenever I can whenever
I have any down time, whenever I am not traveling
as much as I do and I have the skills so it's
something that I can do wherever I am. I can
meditate, I can sit for a practice and even
if it's a few minutes, it's integrated into
my daily life. It's been the most meaningful
life practice that I could have and really
what led me I think to the work that I'm doing
today.
>>Marisa: And you've also become a student
at Columbia doing your master's. So tell us
a little bit about that transition. So you
obviously went back to school at 25 and are
now back in school again. So do you get recognized?
How is it? [laughs]
>>Christy Turlington: It's funny even when
I went to undergrad at NYU, I didn't get recognized
that much. I think students were pretty much
into their own thing and I also -- I don't
know -- I'm not a super glamorous person so
I don't know. I don't think I really stood
out that much even though I was eight years
older than most of my classmates. Now I'm
20 years older [laughs] than all of my classmates,
no maybe not that much, but I'm a lot older
than most of my classmates.
But I also feel that in grad school, at least,
I feel like my professors are my peers like
those are the people that I work with mostly
in this kind of work. So I feel, I feel kind
of like I have an advantage. I feel lucky
that any time I get to be the UN or really
at the table with so many of the people that
are really leaders in the maternal and newborn
child health sector, I feel like my classmates
would be so jealous. [laughs] And I've actually
been able to employ a few of 'em. They been
helping us with some of the education modules
and I really I love the experience. I'm taking
the slow track at the moment so I'll be there
another year or so but I'm enjoying it immensely.
>>Marisa: Very cool. So after this next question,
we'll go ahead and open it up to the audience.
So if you have a question for Christy you
can go here to the mic so people can hear.
But the last question is changing gears to
Google. Do you have a favorite Google product
and how do you use it?
[laughter]
>>Christy Turlington: Well the ones that I
use like daily are -- I mean I constantly
am in the mapping, I mean I'm a big map obsessed
person particularly when it's like global
health. It's so convenient and so user friendly.
So that is one of them. But then the other
is I mean my alerts. I really could not keep
on top of all of the things that are going
on all the time in this space with this issue.
And so I really rely on it so heavily and
then I Tweet like crazy about the different
pieces of information that I get. So it's
been really useful.
>>Marisa: Very cool. Okay.
>>male #1: This is sort of two halves of the
same question. One is you said 90 percent
of these deaths are preventable. What are
some of the key remediations, the key things
to fix? And the second one is, I just imagine
that in most, many of these circumstances,
isn't it really because of the power imbalance
of women do the work and well I don't know
what the men do?
[laughter]
>>Christy Turlington: Well the most important
thing is really prevention. So the importance
of family planning is tremendous. That ties
into education. So education is also incredibly
important. When a girl has more than a primary
education she will just instinctively delay
a first pregnancy, marriage. She'll understand
better to space pregnancies. That will save
her life just by virtue of holding off starting
a family.
Secondly, oh and then obviously having the
ability to control your fertility is tremendously
empowering and incredibly important. So many
women who are pregnant and at a ridiculous
age like 13 or 14 for the first time in much
of Sub-Saharan African and Southeast Asia
-- they have not chosen to be pregnant. They've
not chosen to have sex. So education and working
on that prevention piece and how to empower
girls to protect their own bodies is a critical
piece.
But then the health care worker piece is also
really important. We will never have enough
doctors to fulfill the burden of most global
health issues. And as you heard our obstetrician
in Tanzania say, he was the only OB for 2.5
million people. Well 2.5 million people were
not seeking care from a doctor because they
don't even think about seeing a doctor in
their daily lives. But when a woman is pregnant,
that's an opportunity for a woman to be seen
for the first time. And there are tremendous
things being done with not just community
health workers but midwives and nurses and
midlevel providers.
In Tanzania, the teenager that you see at
the end -- she had a C-section in the end
but by an AMO which is the equivalent of a
physician's assistant. And that's who's doing
the majority of the cesarean sections in Sub-Saharan
Africa, and midwives are doing 'em too actually.
So I would say the skilled birth attendants,
the prevention piece being the family planning
and contraception, and education.
>>female #1: I wanted to thank you so much
I mean I thought the film was great and I
really liked the tone of it. I had worked
in Tanzania a bit before and I liked sort
of the just non-intrusive, I guess, narration.
It just sort of felt like you were letting
the people there interact the way that you
would observe it.
I was curious about the diagnosis the nurse
kept giving some of the patients about their
pelvis bone. So is that linked to I mean is
that a common thing? Is it linked to maybe
being young or is it something with the Maasai
or what was the issue there?
>>Christy Turlington: That's a good question.
It is linked to being too young but also malnutrition
and nutrition --
>>female #1: Okay.
>>Christy Turlington: is a huge factor too.
So these poor women -- they tend to eat last
even when they're pregnant. If they're very
young when they start having a baby, they
don't develop properly. I mean even women
that are older, you just see their stature
as very tiny. And so that was a common I mean
in the amount of time we were in that clinic
that was commonly the reason why a woman had
to be referred. And what happens is if she's
not developed enough and her pelvis is small,
then she's a candidate for an obstructed labor
which in most scenarios ends up where the
baby dies. But in many cases, the woman will
die also and at the very least she'll suffer
a complication, a morbidity which could last
her a lifetime like an obstructed fistula
which is a horrible, horrible handicap --
>>female #1: Um-hum.
>>Christy Turlington: that so many women have.
>>female #1: Okay. Thank you.
>>Christy Turlington: Thank you for the question.
>>Marisa: And we also have a system where
people are putting their questions on and
voting. So we have a few of those. Some of
these we already asked, but I'll go ahead
and ask the first one which is: how do you
feel that your career as a fashion model has
impacted your ability to be an advocate for
women's reproductive health today?
>>Christy Turlington: You know that's a funny
thing. I don't know that -- well I mean I
guess it has certainly helped in a sense because
I sometimes have an opportunity to get some
media attention. But I don't think like the
job itself had any real effect on it. It's
just that it allowed me to really travel and
see the world a lot and I think feel a little
bit more connected to a lot of women outside
of the community where I was raised and where
I was brought up. So I guess the experience
of being able to travel definitely had something
to do with it. And then the fact that I do
have some ability to be able to get some media
attention. I think if I didn't have a deeper
knowledge, I don't know that it would be that
effective.
But the fact that I have made the commitment
to go deeper and to go back to school, I think
will make me a more effective communicator
because it's one thing to communicate what
you see and to tell stories and to go on trips
and to have your picture taken someplace.
But it's another thing to take it to the next
level and to continue to go deeper and to,
for me I really wanna be a part of the solutions
of this problem. I didn't wanna just come
and observe and walk away. I'm deeply committed
to this and I don't know if being a fashion
model has anything to do with that. [chuckles]
>>female #2: Hi I'm Jacqueline. Thanks a lot
for taking on this issue because it's been
a really neglected issue and we really need
people like you to champion it. So thank you.
So a few of us also went with CARE on a maternal
mortality learning trip last year and we went
to Sierra Leone and one of the things that
we learned when we were there is that there
was one pediatrician for all of Sierra Leone.
I mean the country is just so decimated in
terms of health resources. So obviously the
answer to improving maternal mortality has
a lot to do with increasing foreign assistance
and development assistance and I was just
wondering especially now given the cut backs
and given the sort of climate of fear and
holding on to our resources to tightly, how
that's going. How you and Erin are taking
on this issue and are you optimistic at all
and where do you think that's headed?
>>Christy Turlington: That's a good point.
I mean right now is an incredibly tough time
and the budgets are getting slashed on a daily
basis here and for international aid. I think
because we know the next couple years are
gonna be rough, what we're hoping is some
of the momentum that was built around maternal
mortality and maternal health in the last
year, -- it was on the agenda for the first
time at the G8 last summer -- that all of
that and some of the attention that Bill and
Linda Gates have brought to it and Sarah Brown,
Gordon Brown's wife. I mean some of those
things have escalated the issue to now be
-- it's on the agenda.
So our priority is keeping it a focus so that
we don't fell back. The idea is like, "Okay
we can't do a whole lot with aid right now
but we can sort of keep pushing along." And
we believe that civil society hasn't really
been a part of this dialog yet. And we hope
that the film and the exposure on something
like the Oprah Winfrey Network and our partnership
with Starbucks and the CD we've created -- that
those are ways to really bring in everyday
citizens, moms, family members to get to be
a part of this, to participate. And I mean
we really envision us playing a big role -- like
that we actually can be a part of helping
to bridge some of that funding gap that exists
now.
>>Marisa: And we have a question about volunteering
and being able to help. Are there things that
people can do from here?
>>Christy Turlington: Yeah -- we often get
that question and we're trying to really identify
a few ways that people can have meaningful
results. And some of those are volunteering.
They might not mean you have to leave this
country. There are ways to be able to create
watch parties and host parties and to learn
more so that you can then have a voice within
your community and create your own constituency
around this issue and have your voice heard.
Because there are so many women and girls
who do not have a voice and so my, the main
thing that you can do that anyone could do
is to use your voice 'cause you have one.
But the second thing is I mean we have, we're
trying to identify a few very easy ways, tangible
ways and we have identified a few organizations
there you can donate phones, phones that you
don't use anymore, that you've discarded.
We have ways that you can help support midwives
and the education of midwives to get supplies
into their hands that they are better able
to do a job.
We're gonna have some of those ready for our
launch on May 7th and we do invite you to
come back to the site and to look at it 'cause
we'll give you some very specific ideas and
ways you can do things.
>>Marisa: In addition to being on the Oprah
Winfrey Network, is it also going to be released
more widely? How will people be able to see
it? They'll be able to see it on May 7th and
--
>>Christy Turlington: Yes, well OWN will be
our broadcast partner here and then they have
the digital and video rights. So it will be
part of -- she's gonna have a documentary
club kind of like her book club and we'll
be a part of that. And then OWN will also
broadcast it in Canada under another network
called CORUS who's gonna be distributing OWN.
And then we'll be doing also broadcasts in
France around their Mother's Day which is
at the end of May and that's gonna happen
on Teva which is a women's channel there.
We'll try to identify in the G8 markets where
they do celebrate Mother's Day because Mother's
Day is not an international, an internationally
celebrated event, but those are kind of key
moments where it could be launched.
And then we're continuing to travel with it
at global health conferences. I've been showing
it for the last year since we launched at
Tribeca to really get it out there amongst
the community.
>>Marisa: How has making this film changed
your view on motherhood?
>>Christy Turlington: Hmm. Well I think I
there's not a whole lot that I can complain
about as a mom [laughs] or as a working person.
My mother will tell me all the time, "Oh you're
working so hard. You really have to slow down."
And I said, "You have no idea what hard work
is until you go out in the world." So the
stuff that I do, it's like the very least
I can do because I can do it and I can choose
to do the things that I do and I can choose
to donate my time and my energy to an issue
like this.
I think the appreciation of having had the
health care workers that I had that helped
me in my own situation while delivering, I
mean I have tremendous respect and did from
day one for midwives and for doctors and for
nurses because they really are the unsung
heroes around the world and I truly believe
that.
And I think for my children, I'm the best
example I can be as a human being for them.
Like that's my first priority and I think
by the stuff that I'm interested in, the things
that I'm sort of pursuing, they're seeing
that and they're getting exposed to the world
and the issues, the real issues that I think
really matter at a really young age. I think
that's like an invaluable thing that I can
give them and I can't wait to be able to share
more of the world with them and have them
help me. I can't wait to be side by side with
my daughter working on these issues. So she's
seven and a half now I figure I give her another
couple years and then [laughs] drag her on
the road with me. [laughs]
>>Marisa: Okay well I guess we will have Christy
here to take more questions if you guys wanna
come up and meet her and ask more questions
in person.
But I wanna thank you so much for coming today
and sharing the film with us and a bit of
your story. It's really great.
>>Christy Turlington: Thank you so much.
[applause]